[Music]
right some of these you would have heard
but right try and keep a straight face
you have to make eye contact with me
with you yeah okay
and then try not to laugh okay okay
right so this one i think you would have
heard before actually right
what do you call a fish with no eyes
[Laughter]
all right that was actually funny
those
right next one ready
yeah go
number two i've got 10 of these right
what do you call a can opener that
doesn't work
i can't open it yes
oh well done
did you hear all right
did you hear about the italian chef that
died
no
he passed away
but
i sold my vacuum the other day
all it was doing was collecting dust
nice
what's all right what's forrest gump's
password
i don't know
one forest one
[Laughter]
i couldn't even say it
yeah i'm not laughing at it i'm laughing
at you
as soon as you said one your mouth
your mother was quivering
my mouth was actually quivering oh
that's funny bro my mouth was quivering
[ __ ] it awesome oh right
oh fam
i like elephants
everything else is irrelevant
um
oh god
what kind of tea is hard to swallow
tell me
reality
[Laughter]
that one is just
three more okay
what did the janitor say when he jumped
out of the closet
i don't know supplies
well played he held it he held it you
held it
that was a good one yeah
what did the buffalo say when he when
his son left
bye son wait
bye son
oh right
last one that was a good one as well
ready yeah
what do you call a frenchman in sandals
felipe flopping
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
oh my god philippe
oh my god yeah the first one spun me
yeah the first one spun me i can't
remember where it was what was the first
one me
from the one forest one i couldn't keep
my jaw sticking
that was funny that was actually funnier
than i thought that one
[Music]
you